Một quan hán ở kuy môi nhỏ tại khu sình cửa,
có thể tiếp nhận hàng trăm sâu sịch trong ngày.
Khi lượng khách tăng dành, bức kìm chát từng sâu sịch trình hoàn
tù công, dế dân định nhầm lẫn vả trạm chế.
Thấy vì liên tục kìm chá đi thoại,
nhiều chủ quan đã lưu trọng nhận tiền kênh hợp với thông báo sư sư từ
loa sọ bóng, đã tại quay thinh hoán,
môi khi có tiền về tại hoàn, loa tế phát thông báo ngay là tức,
loa sọ bóng, được ở buổi là em bên tù gần hệ âm thành trình sách,
cần mất nhất quán.
Giả pháp này có lợi thế,
nhanh bên hoặc chục hoán chỉ cần nghe tu báo để xác nhận sâu sịch.
Chục hoán có thể sẽ sẵn lối sách tàn bộ sân tù của ngay,
bức quan lý sông kìm chả điên, mình bạch báo tật hơn.
Hấp thời, bình ngay này người tư xuống cũng đã sử dụng trình hoàn,
quên mạc hua nhiều hơn tình bạch.
Chông sịch cao điểm của năm,
bình bi bán chính, kay chính xin đude ái sản cho hục kiên xanh,
với mức quà tạng lên đến năm chân ghi đồng.
Cho các cái hạn lần kì, bà sử dụng sẽ pháp thông tàn toàn về QR phà xam ốc.
Bán có thể đang kì tại quá sài bình bi bán,
mọc tử các điểm xong sịch gần nhất này, tư bân.